[Music]
this incredible crystalline structure is
made of living starfish embryos this was
an absolutely remarkable uh phenomena
that has never been reported before
individual starfish embryos spin in the
water but when several come together an
ordered repeating pattern emerges
this is what's called a living crystal
and physicists have been trying to
understand its fascinating properties
a starfish living in a research
laboratory is not an entirely unusual
site
what might seem odd however is that this
starfish is living in a physics lab i'm
not a biologist i'm interested in
biological phenomena but i think physics
is a lens through which you can look at
a wide range of biological phenomena and
find common
laws nichta fakhri is interested in a
branch of physics studying so-called
active matter active matter refers to
any collection of
entities that individually use energy to
generate their own motion and force when
these active entities come together
unusual things can happen
individuals acting independently can in
a group spontaneously form larger scale
shapes i'm sure the majority of us have
looked into the sky and have seen a
large number of birds flying together
and of course when you look from far
away what you end up seeing is something
that looks like a cloud that is moving
and changing shape and really coherently
moving in the sky active mata systems
can have unusual properties and
physicists like nichta want to
understand exactly how these come about
her most recent work looks at tiny
starfish embryos in a dish we put these
starfish embryos that are swimming in
water together and once you have enough
of their neighbors they form a very
large structure which is as you can see
quite ordered and we call this a crystal
a crystalline material is one made from
a repeating arrangement of particles for
example atoms lined up in identical rows
and columns
and this is what nichta's team saw when
they looked down the microscope but the
starfish embryos a repeating lattice
just like a crystal
we know we have crystals of many uh
materials but we have never really uh
related the formation of a crystal with
components that are actually living the
living crystal forms as the result of
each individual embryo spinning in the
water
when two embryos interact both rotating
in the same direction the forces between
them start to create a structure with
strange properties what you actually see
is that there are waves that are going
through this crystal very large scale
waves as large as the crystal itself and
these waves are persisting for very long
times and this was an absolutely uh
incredible discovery
waves in water usually dissipate very
quickly these waves can only persist
because of the active nature of the
embryos the fact that they're using
energy and moving independently
it's not clear whether this behavior has
any benefit for the starfish but
understanding how it comes about could
allow researchers to design new
materials or devices i can now take this
design rule and i can encode that into
small robots
and then i can have a collection of
these robots
and then what i will end up actually
building is a robotic swarm
[Music]